[Musique]
il aurait été insupportable pour les
policiers
pour le ministre de l'intérieur mais
pour tous les français que ces personnes
puissent continuer à vivre en toute
liberté
au total quatre personnes sont en garde
à vue le tireur présumé un complice
présumé le chauffeur du véhicule et
c'est un message de nez à tous ceux qui
veulent s'en prendre aux policiers aux
gendarmes
on vous laissera jamais tranquille et en
quatre jours on a démontré on a démontré
qu'on laissera jamais tranquille des
trafiquants se sont cette fois des
militaires d'actifs qui publie cette
tribune comme la précédente sur le site
de valeurs actuelles
ils s'en prennent tout d'abord aux
détracteurs du premier texte
ces gens qui ont lutté contre tous les
ennemis de la france
vous les avez traité de factieux alors
que leur seul tort est d'aimer leur pays
et de pleurer ça visible déchéance plein
aujourd'hui des gens qui cultivent en
fait là aussi une forme de souvenirs
mais en fait quelque chose
une france que je trouve très étriqué
dénonce la perte de sens civique que
l'affaiblissement des institutions mais
ils y participent
puisqu'il publier des tribunes ce qui me
pends semble pas la vocation aux
premières désarmés si facilement c'est
le langage de l'insécurité qu'il
utilisait chez vous pour parler de ces
réalités
c'est à dire on va utiliser tout un
vocabulaire euphémisé c'est tout un
vocabulaire qui cherche quelques fois
précédemment neutralisée la réalité des
choses on va parler de bandes de jeunes
des civilités de quartiers sensibles
on va parler de donc on voit qu'avec une
fois de d'agression au couteau
apparemment on le poignard de plus je
voudrais reprendre un manque a dit tout
à l'heure
votre journaliste pour moi il n'y a pas
de sédition il n'y a pas une seule fois
le mot nous allons sortir de nos
casernes pour faire un putsch en prenons
seulement tôt ou un coup d'état
lorsqu'en plus vient le temps de lever
la dimension culturelle de tout cela qui
peut être présente
alors là les pressions de tongs c'est de
toucher au tabou des tabous nous avons
connu l'opération sentinelles nous avons
subi les tentatives
d'instrumentalisation de plusieurs
communautés religieuses pour qui la
france ne signifie rien qu'un objet de
sarcasmes de mépris voire de haine
c'est seul courage d'être anonyme
monsieur sont des militaires d'actifs
le temps d'être of steel n'a autant m
bah oui quand on veut faire de la
politique on se présente aux élections
cette déchéance nous l'avons vu dans
bien des pays en crise elle précède
l'effondrement elle annonce le chaos et
la violence
je ne nie pas ce qui peut se produire
des mouvements extrémistes qui infiltre
un certain nombre de corps sociaux et y
compris nos armées mais le vrai problème
et
et preuve de méthode on devrait même pas
donner crédit à ce que vient de faire
valeurs actuelles dans la mesure où
quand il n'y a pas de signature
y a pas de texte je suis révoltée de
voir que certains choisissent de s'en
prendre aux messagers pour ne pas
écouter le message est et qu'on est prêt
à décrire ces militaires qui servent la
france comme des factieux si je la
soutiens c'est qu'évidemment il ne
s'agit pas du tout d'un appel à
l'insurrection il s'agit d'un constat
un constat que font des millions de
français en réalité et qui devrait être
prise au sérieux par l'exécutif
cette tribune utilise toute la
rhétorique le vocabulaire le ton les
références qui sont celles de l'extrême
droite alors dans quel but
certainement le but de diviser
si marine le pen voulait vraiment
défendre l'intérêt des français à le
retirer toutes ces candidatures de
toutes ces candidats lire et faire autre
chose pour notre pays
ce que l'extrême droite n'est jamais
dans l'intérêt d'une population que ce
soit en france en europe ou ailleurs
dans le monde plus de distanciation
sociale revoici les câlins le hug fait
son grand retour au royaume uni cela
valait bien des unes de journaux grâce
aux bons chiffres du cor vides le
gouvernement permette à nouveau les
contacts entre proches michel fourniret
un homme à l'effroyable parcours
criminel qui emporte avec lui ses
secrets mort à 79 ans dans l'unité
sécurisé d'un hôpital parisien
il souffrait d'insuffisance respiratoire